[موسيقى]
هذا الذي يكتب على فيسبوك
هل هذا الذي يكتب على فيسبوك هو يكتب
القصه من مكان الذي شاهد فيه هذه القصه
طبعا هو هناك
من الذين يستخدمون الفيسبوك
لانه فكره المواطن الصحفي المحترمه لا
تزال في ثورها المبكر فبالتالي انت بتلاقي
بوستات كثيره مسروقه وافكار كثيره
[موسيقى]
هل الاشكاليه ناتجه من ان ظهور مثل هذه
التجارب يعني لا تعتبر لا للمشاهير ولا
الفيسبوك ولا ما تعتبر صحافه نتكلم على
الصحافه
بصناعتها الصلبه قائمه للتدريب والمهاره
والخبرات والمسؤوليه ايضا يعني يتحمل
الصحفي يختلف انه يتحمل المؤسسه الصحفي
المؤسسه الاعلاميه كانت تتحمل مسؤوليه
افعاله
اذا احنا نتكلم على غياب صحافه في مكان هو
نتيجه الضعف في الاداء الاعلامي وليس
نتيجه ظهور انا اعتقد انه هو كان هناك
فراغ شغله هؤلاء
[موسيقى]
من يملك
وسائط الاجتماعيه
[موسيقى]